okay so I woke up this morning and I was
flipping through news and I saw this
news article that said that Marvel the
Marvel movies were considering making
Xavier and Magneto black guys and so
then I was like okay I wonder what the
Internet's reaction is to this right
because oftentimes when it comes to
stuff like that like the alt-right side
of the the chemical community and then
looking at like the rest of the Internet
as a whole it's usually kind of fun and
just kind of sit back and watch things
pop off right like it's just kind of
funny to watch things go crazy right
because uh more often than not it's
usually people who were just too heavily
invested in comics I'm in reading for 25
years I'm not really like heavily
invested in coming about characters
anymore I was like 20 years ago but not
anymore that was just kind of like
things games whatever who cares but I'm
also 35 I kind of stopped giving a crap
a while ago ah so the funny thing about
this is I I was going through and I was
looking at these different articles and
some of the reference the source
material some of them didn't but the
ones who reference them from what I've
been able to tell all this stems from
full circle cinema right this website
that had this article and the title of
the article is Marvel Studios
considering making Professor X and
Magneto people of color and x-men reboot
and apparently is an exclusive so I said
okay let's let's read this like this
because I mean right out the top like
that's that's what's super clickbait
title right so you know in this day and
age one of the things you kind of have
to be aware of when it comes to the news
is it's really more about titling than
it is about the article and so sometimes
you get back sometimes you don't write
on me in this day and age there's no
real differentiation between like the
onion and everything else right so I was
like okay let's let's read the article
and let's see what it says right here's
what the article says the x-men could
have a unique twist to them when Marvel
Studios rules out their inevitable
reboot Kevin Feige and company are
considering making people of color
portray both Magneto and Professor X in
the MCU full circle cinema has learned
that first statement is very very
important
while this change wouldn't alter much
for Charles Xavier as he was born in New
York to a wealthy family it may lead to
Marvel Studios taking some liberties
with era clinchers origin in the pages
of Marvel Comics magneto was born in the
1920s to a Jewish family during World
War 2 Erik was sent to Auschwitz a Nazi
concentration camp not really sure why
you need to be told as a concentration
camp it's one of the most historical and
important places in the history of the
world because the atrocities
committed there with the current MCU
taking place in 2023 is difficult to
imagine a near 100 year old magneto
taking on the x-men Marvel Studios will
also have some difficulty of some steps
I'm sorry
Marvel Studios will also have to take
some steps to differentiate its
incarnation of the x-men from what Fox
has done over the better part of the
last two decades making two of the
potential leads of the franchise people
of color could be a huge step in doing
that as well as helping to push the
diversity of the MCU forward earlier
this year Kevin Feige spoke about
representation in the MCU and how he
believes it's the future of the
franchise so the notion of
representation on-screen I'm quoting
Kevin Feige here like they did so quote
the notion of us so the notion of
representation on screen in front of and
behind the camera somebody asked me once
so is black panther a one-off I said no
it's not a one-off flag II told the RAF
this is the future this is the way the
world is and in the way certainly our
studio is going to be run going forward
because it brings about better stories
the more diverse the group of people
making the movie is the better the
stories when the x-men in quote when the
x-men were to make their live-action
debut for the 2015 film Fox enlisted
veteran actors Patrick Stewart and Ian
McKellen to tackle the role of Professor
X and Magneto
they would portray the characters until
the studio decided to do a soft reboot
of the franchise with x-men first class
and James McAvoy and Michael Fassbender
took over the roles
although McKellen and Stewart would
appear again in Days of Future past
alongside their younger counterparts now
basically it ends and says would you be
excited to see Professor X and Magneto
people of color in the MCU who should
portray the duo in Marvel Studios x-men
reboot let us know in the comments below
here's my question at what point
anywhere in the article does it say that
Marvel Studios is considering making
Magneto and Professor X black guys like
at what point in that article at what
point and what Kevin Feige said does
that seem to be the case what Kevin
Feige said is we want more diversity on
and off camera
like more diverse people making movies
and more diverse people in movies at
what point did Kevin Feige even
referenced the x-men in what he said so
this is a combination of two things this
is a combination of a news company being
lazy by creating a clickbait title and
then not having much
going on in the concert I mean they
literally said like like what is it uh
that that Marvel Studios is considering
having people of color play both Magneto
and Professor X in the MCU full circle
cinema has learned where do they learn
that like literally because all this all
this comes down to is like Marvel wants
to make the x1 wants to make Magneto and
Professor X black you have to believe us
that's basically what this comes down to
so this is a combination of two things
it's it's a news company being lazy
trying to make a name for themselves and
in the end like I imagine it'll backfire
because I think people who read the
article will realize like they're just
making [ __ ] up basically and then it's a
is the other side of it is just people
being lazy people reading the headline
and not reading the article but that's
really all that comes down to there's no
way you could read this entire article
and walk away from it believing that
Marvel wants to make Professor X and
Magneto black guys there's there's no
reason there's no way that a reasonable
human being could walk away and believe
that right I mean you could believe that
if you want to believe that right like
if what you're doing is you're looking
at the idea like if you're an individual
who's like I'm not in favor of just like
making a white person black although I
am in favor of making a white
american-british which I've never really
understood how you reconcile that right
I mean if the legacy of the character is
important well the legacy stays
important you know regardless of what
their skin color is I mean it's not like
everything that Xavier did was based on
his skin color he was a part of Friends
of humanity which was basically a
stand-in for the Klan but against
mutants he wasn't part of like the right
which is this crazy right-wing
organization in the comics he wasn't a
part of like William strikers purifiers
which were like these evangelical
Christians who believed God wants him to
kill mutants there was nothing that
Xavier really did that was predicated on
I'm doing this and I can do it because
I'm a white guy like it's nothing was
based on that right so if the legacy is
that important to you then their skin
color wouldn't matter so like that dog
don't bark right that that argument
doesn't flood argument doesn't float but
maybe in the world of it it does because
everything floats we all float but uh
but yeah it's people who just who didn't
read the article and just ran what ran
off with a headline right it's just
people being lazy is all it really is I
mean if you're a person who just read
the headline and didn't read the article
then I'm calling you lazy like that's
basically what it is I mean you're
you're a lazy human being because it's
it's silly like it's it's nuts people
are getting bad out of shape about
nothing right they're getting banished
it about theirs
like if one it's a rumor so even even if
even if Marvel was considering it like
they're considering it right like Sony
was considering a movie we're like Aunt
May was a secret agent we never got it
thank God but like I mean it's it's it's
even if there was some shred of truth to
it you'd be based on a rumor they they
like this news article offers nothing to
back up their claim and the information
they do provide has nothing to do with
their claim right so for all the glitz
and glamour here they might as well have
titled this article Marvel Studios
considering making Professor X and
Magneto people have color in the x-men
reboot and then talked about stars and
rainbows that that's what they might
have will have done here because it
doesn't really matter for anything now
the purpose is served because they have
me and other people talking about it but
hopefully talking about it will bring
light will shed light on this and then
kind of reveal that like they're full of
[ __ ] and then people will kind of
consider them to be an unreliable source
right because my question after this and
after reading this article was well
maybe these guys are like the Charlie
intel of the MCU world where like
Charlie intel is a guy who basically has
all the inside information on call of
duty right so like if Charlie intel
comes out on Twitter and says here's
what at what Activision is thinking
about doing it like here's what
Activision is doing with like the newest
Call of Duty
you can usually take it as gospel truth
right because Charlie intel has almost
never been wrong so I was looking at
this and I was like okay well maybe full
circle cinemas one of these groups were
like they have a following because like
they usually like they have inside
information and they kind of throw it
out and they keep their sources secrets
they don't have to worry about losing
their jobs at Marvel Studios
no I haven't found anything about that
like this channels it doesn't show the
subscriber count' they get like 200
views of videos so almost like okay I
mean like from what I understand it's a
small little you know little news thing
I guess I don't know if they're owned by
anybody else but there's nothing out
there that indicates that like they've
got inside sources and this is a thing
to be believed it just sounds like
they're full of [ __ ] and they were just
making a clickbait article so um hey
here's the important thing guys don't
just read titles aren't that's a lazy
man's response right I don't just read
the title I mean if that were the case
then like the New York Times could print
an article called the world's ending and
then people would lose their minds
because I thought the world was
literally ending when in reality the
world is ending in like the boys TV show
on Amazon and it was just that people
freaked out because they were too lazy
to read the article right so don't be
lazy
right don't be a lazy person who just
doesn't take the time to read an article
like read the contents of the article
and then what you'll find is instead of
sitting in these circumstances and
having
on your face like you do you'll actually
go through there and realize hey maybe I
shouldn't say anything because they
don't look like an idiot when the truth
comes out but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
uh if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
[Music]
Oh
[Music]